so you're going to do the expando
waistline uh sweatpants is that what
you're thinking of john
traditionally that's the room
traditionally no jeans i think that's a
great
idea yeah i if i think if you really
don't want to eat a lot you should put
on those
really tight spandex yoga pants
and then that that keeps you get you
full really fast
now i think everybody's looking forward
to hopefully a very nice thanksgiving
albeit
probably smaller than it's been in a
while let's look outside it is chillier
than it was yesterday morning
minus the winds we've got nice clear
skies good sunshine everybody
valley temperatures right now are very
cool we've got mid 30s the mountain's
edge
38 at nellis 20s up at kyle canyon and
kingman has dropped to the 20s this
morning red rock
at 30 degrees it is cold out there
everybody so
here's your thanksgiving forecast we're
looking at some mid 40s by 8 a.m
tomorrow
it is going to be very windy tomorrow
i'm sorry to say we're looking at near
30 mile per hour winds in the afternoon
and highs cooler too probably just under
60 degrees wind advisories have already
been issued
for the lake and the river areas not las
vegas
per se but definitely looking at outside
areas
getting 40 to 50 mile an hour winds for
thursday
still kind of windy on friday
temperatures warm back up to the mid 60s
sunday with some clouds on monday let's
go